I have a new opening okay good morning
I told you we should keep the cowbell
all right now they're gonna get rid of
it Samson Oh keep it and you were 100
cent right well cuz I know I the way
your instincts work yeah there's good
use for it that's right
it's red it's in front of me it's got to
be used that's right welcome to the show
it's a celebration in here sure is
thirsty Thursdays it's exciting it
really is an exciting time to be alive
and I feel that I feel good about all of
us and the team effort do you feel good
about us as humans I do I feel good
about us as humans
I feel color brave I didn't know that
was a term color brave I didn't either
but sometimes it just takes a a mishap
in a coffee place to teach us all that
race to be colored brain it's really
important in a colorblind you call it
brave do you think Starbucks like had a
committee think of that for them it's
it's it's it's it's weird to watch a
corporation of that magnitude
you know panic so completely I mean it's
insane and to look at the the videos and
the team guidebook and the my notebook
and to listen to the west-world
robotic language there's zero humanity
and at the zero sincerity and that
there's zero common [ __ ] experience
in it
there's absolutely no reality to any of
it it's it's it's nobody's experience
utter [ __ ] right that's it it's utter
[ __ ] that's it isn't it high from one
human to another human I would like to
shut the [ __ ] up what are you talking
about my coffee so on coffee yesterday
unfortunately due to Lewis J Gomez I
mean I've never seen anybody get get all
wound up in an argument like that Pat
was a fire but you know I
this was kind of spinning in circles a
little bit where it was like again he
was Duggan it was like a wildfire yeah I
think you knew it it wasn't a controlled
blaze no I think that Louis knew it
right I thought it was likes to do the
radio I do too I think Louis is the type
that when he starts when he starts going
down a path and realizing that it's an
argument he likes to stay there yeah he
doesn't care if it's right or wrong he's
not the sound good
but which I guess is it he's actually a
better broadcaster than he gets credit
for because he just wants it to sound
good that's right he doesn't really care
if he's right or being made an ass out
of as he was yesterday he just cares
about being good on an entertaining on
the air right which is probably the goal
we should all have I guess so although I
mean there's also nothing wrong with
actually putting something out there
that's oh yeah we're saying that you're
wrong when you feel like you're wrong
yeah I don't think that there's there's
it's two schools of thought yeah but we
didn't get to watch Starbucks is the
beginning of their training video really
important stuff you remember this week
they canceled everything for an
afternoon they shut down eight thousand
stores good so that they could send all
the employees to racial bias training
because Starbucks was racist for a long
time sure and they didn't know it and
you know that when you see the guys in
Seattle who are really running the
corporation they just didn't understand
that it was happening on the ground they
didn't understand yeah yeah racism that
they had fostered on the ground hmm they
didn't realize they've been up in the
ivory tower so long they weren't down
with the troops they weren't down there
with the ground troops and they didn't
realize that out of the probably what is
it four or five million transactions a
day they do they had two that were not
good right and that needed to have the
entire company in an upheaval I also
love that they and I guess all
corporations kind of do this they make
it seem like there's some kind of group
mentality here yes us right but we've
all had our lis jobs like we've all
worked in fast-food places or stores in
the mall or wherever and when you work
at a place like that for minimum wage
when you have basically stalker patties
job you don't feel like you're part of
the Starbucks team
no and you don't care you don't care at
all if if you're making $12 an hour at
Starbucks and the competitor says hey
four you can come over here
for 1225 you're going cuz it doesn't
matter you're just there for the check
what watching them handle it like this
it's fun to watch them completely panic
you know if they just made that after
that second video say all right from now
on here's new company policy you cannot
use the restroom until you have already
made your purchase that's a store wide
policy for all customers problem solved
or you know it could have happened they
could have just not talked about it and
it would have just gone away not one
eventually would went away the first the
first one was bad but the second one
what do I want the bad thing would have
gone away a hundred percent they did not
need to institute a new bathroom policy
at Starbucks but they also as much as
this one wouldn't have gone away the
Philly one where people got arrested for
sitting down or according to Lewis J
Gomez shouting make me while wearing
they're doing exactly basically being
Black Panthers and starting a riot so
this is two real estate guys but it
wouldn't have gone away but they didn't
need to react with this much drama I've
never seen yeah an overreaction like
this we just talked about Roseanne
yesterday and I've never seen a reaction
like this either
yeah this is a bigger overreaction than
the Roseanne fire and by far by far so
let's watch the first few minutes of the
Starbucks training video so that because
it's important yeah I mean I don't think
it's just Starbucks that should stop
being racist I think it's all of us I
want to foster sameness such a good idea
you know and wait as as people that are
raising the generation under us we
should teach them all about sameness and
eliminating cultures do they say
diversity is good or bad though I don't
know how that works
they say that we shouldn't see anything
but yet diversity is important and we
should embrace diversity but yet if you
enjoy somebody's culture and adopt any
of it that's cultural appropriation so
are we supposed to just kind of look at
culture and go boy that's good or person
that's good you can enjoy and appreciate
a culture but if you start to adopt any
of it you have to be heavily researched
on the culture and be giving back to
important stuff so thank you for the
clarification
yes it's very very important
without a doubt the events in
Philadelphia prompted us to bring a
thousand stores and a hundred and
seventy-five thousand partners together
mark even calling it I had a problem
before partners even calling it the
events in Philadelphia I was just saying
the arrests yeah they're talking about
it like it's 9/11 why don't you just use
though but this is what they do in these
first of all it's this silly ideology
and it's also this corporate corporate
speak yeah the events just say it the
arrests right remember it was remember
when we arrested those black guys in
Philadelphia [ __ ] up yeah you [ __ ]
up I like 135,000 partners partners
they're all partners do you feel like
that you feel like look we ranked at
Sirius XM higher than a lot of people if
you feel like you're a partner of Sirius
XM I feel like I'm disposable baby why
[Laughter]
because that is not who we aspire to be
important 529 is an opportunity to renew
our commitment to the third place five
to 529 is the date that's not all I know
it isn't
that's what five you're right 529 is the
date like 529 that's like the Newt the
rebirth oh my god
yeah yeah 529 is how they were gonna
refer to it I didn't even get I was like
what's 529 like the policy number
no no they really are again you're
acting like it's 9/11 they really are
because the time that the that ugly
racism crashed into our two giant
coffees and they they opening the team
guidebook which we are lucky enough to
have the team guys look who's got some
Oh for pete's sake I knocked my clip off
my notebook well yeah don't knock it off
your notebook the team guide books
important stuff thick is a mug yeah this
thing is a mug [ __ ] guide me to
Colleen it's very very good yeah we've
got a looks like it's about 70 pages
yeah it's a 70 page guide book about how
we cannot be racist anymore but we the
first thing is really important is our
mission page 1 our mission because we
want to uplift others we exist to
inspire and nurture the human spirit
one person one cup and one neighborhood
at a time because we want to uplift
others we exist I think it's important
to not be overly dramatic do you I'm
glad they handle that well I feel
inspired when you when you order your
coffee and then just five minutes later
they just shout Jim and it's there they
never they never shot that just never
the name I give but they'll shout Edgar
or chip yes I did feel inspired
so when Rob goes down to get the
coffee's in the morning he sometimes
comes back with up to four beverages he
must be just given a dose of inspiration
like nobody can handle yeah he's
hoarding it from everyone else with all
that coffee they're new they're their
phrase that keeps being repeated
throughout this guidebook every human
scene respected uplifted uplifted he
wanted go into a coffee place and then
being like you know what you can have a
great day today and you know why because
you're worth it well did you read what I
tweeted last night I tweeted something I
read online from this it was a a little
piece of it and the language they use
the robotic language that is good I just
love it so you have to click on what I
wrote just click on what they wrote
Starbucks executive vice president Rose
Ann Williams gave an example I guess
this is from one of these books okay
claiming she observed a breeze to
approach a customer who was using
uncomfortable language and say you are
in our store every day and we love that
this is your third place but from one
human to another human the language that
you are using is making other customers
uncomfortable so either you have to
change your behavior and stay and be a
part of our third place or I'm going to
have to ask you to leave and you can
come back at a later time when you feel
like you can be a part of our third
place and in fact if you want to go have
a seat I'll bring you over a cup of
water just to make sure it's a great
rest of your day
that's the that's the West how does it
know West world discussion she heard in
a Starbucks for some shorter place it's
not just some corporate [ __ ] creating
something for the book oh yeah no no no
she observed it and either you have to
change your behavior and stay and be a
part of our third place what's third
place third place is what Starbucks is I
guess the first place is your home okay
I mean I don't maybe the second is your
job I don't know I haven't gotten that
deep into it I see and III my third
place it was different what was your
third my [ __ ] okay I see which was
far as tickling is concern but the first
of all but from one human to another
human who the [ __ ] talks like that
what type of robotic insincere [ __ ] one
human we know what you are do you ever
need the species clarify to you and
you're discussing this with someone I
had no point in any conversation in my
life that I've ever had with anybody
have I looked at them going like I
wonder if they're a human being
well let me say I have had to do that
I've said look from one human to
management but if management came to me
and said Sam you know from one human to
another human we're trying to make
serious a third place for the people and
that's that's what we like to think of
as the product that goes out there we're
like family
what are you talking about man what are
you talking about it's um
Scott Missouri says this is the
progressive left and it will hurt them
let's go to God what so this is the
thing yeah I kind of agree I kind of
don't yes Scott yeah sorry I think the
of this overreaction in this
oversensitivity I think all purposes
it's just a product of this the
progressive left and I think the more
that they just keep pushing and pushing
and pushing people are finally going to
get set up with and just at you know
[ __ ] it and you think they are turning
off some Democrats that either will not
go to the polls or they may even vote
GOP I you know I think they're they're
just going this today's Democratic Party
is not the Democratic Party
don't think there's there's complete
madness on both sides crazy this is what
happens you take it's a liberal ideology
but it's also when a corporation gets
involved and they make it this
structured and they make it like let's
saw it all change that it's it's both
sides it's it's it's horrendous here's
what's going on this is just today just
today on the far left side of things
you've got influence that is causing
corporations to have behavior where you
have people going up to other people
going from a human to another human but
on the GOP side of things you've got a
president who's meeting with Kim
Kardashian in the Oval Office so it's
like what do we what what's our choices
here it's really all it's terrible
you're right there are there's there's
extremes on both sides and I think most
Americans are somewhere in the middle
but I think if you could take those
people in the middle and just ask them
honestly I think they they are getting
kind of fed up with this this
progressive kind of I'll call it
[ __ ] but you know that just this
overreaction culture and it is gradually
pushing some of those people in the
middle pushing them to the right even
they might not want to go but they're
it's like they're holding their nose and
like well I'm not a big fan of the right
but I sure as [ __ ] a fan of yeah of
this stuff your song about GOP it's the
language police but it's also as you get
older that happens - when you say push
it's because as years go on people get
older a lot of times they change a
little bit yeah that's an age thing -
you know the older you get the more you
like art the [ __ ] don't tell me what the
thing you know you just start getting
annoyed I think Joe in New Jersey
probably the best take on all of this
what's up Joe Joe how do you do Joe how
are you fabulous
another human oh yeah go Joe sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt you in your
third play okay hello
[Laughter]
this is just [ __ ] coffee there's more
important things to worry about this
world like chance like transgenders or
as I like to call them hybrid this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
it's coffee I love you guys and take
care and God bless thank you both
from one human to another human yeah it
really is
it's [ __ ] crazy oh such a little more
I think we should I don't want to lose
focus no you're right you're right from
one but from one human to another I
appreciate you playing
I'll ask my human guy I don't wanna say
I don't wanna say friend our partner our
partner partner Troy it's a call this is
how cults speak by the way it's it's
completely Harlan is one who raised the
point about like how you you remove the
humanity when you add syllable it was
it's one of the greatest points of
comedians ever made about anything but
when you look at how they do it there's
no Humanity in it when you add syllables
we like you saying when a dump becomes a
landfill and how shellshock became
post-traumatic stress it's just this
whole genius it's it's great absolutely
brilliant but when you look at there's
no human connection in any of these
little words it's just from one human to
another it's it's really robotic life ya
partner Troy would you mind continuing
on with the clip let's proceed how does
the partner of taps feel I think
anything personal you guys should be
storing in your notebooks for reflection
later that's a great point great happen
to two valuable point what makes you you
write me me that's it that's a great
great point great point go ahead guys
thank you the third place because we
understand that racial and systemic bias
have many causes sources by the ways
I've shown here it's like a child story
in in the video the [ __ ] book that
they're turning
it's like watching it's a massive it's
like looking at one of those photo books
in a store where the giant book on
display yeah when you saw the Atlas in
the library total yes
look at the World Cup within each of us
and in our communities so to get things
going
Kevin will welcome teams we are here to
make Starbucks there's a crybaby pulled
his [ __ ] face out of a sunlamp
look at red-faced idiot you may get a
tanning bed before the big oh my god not
racist video he's [ __ ] his rosacea
panic you think he's getting blotchy as
he realized the killer judging him he is
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's collapsing under the
weight of the racism but this is what
happens when people are so out of touch
with what happened they see something
like that yeah it was shitty but to be
shocked like to be shocked to the point
where you shake up your company like
this and embarrass your entire
corporation like this publicly if you
really are against what happened there
all you have to do is be like yep that
one employee did not reflect our values
we've decided to let her go and move on
you know or just do what he did he met
with those guys on the news but that was
humiliating but he met with the guys he
talked to them that's great that's what
you got to do some [ __ ] up and you
know the girl whatever she maybe
overreacted a little bit let's try not
to do that anymore but there's a hundred
and set well you have a hundred and
seventy five thousand employees you're
gonna have people if one of your
employees is literally screaming the
n-word and throwing coffee at a customer
that's still not too many considering
than 175,000 if one employee of their
partner one partner a day gets coffee
and says what you order this alright
that's very bad but it's one out of a
hundred and seventy-five thousand people
percentage-wise it's very low right
you're still doing really really
exceptionally well you're doing
exceptionally well if you have the
occasional incident where somebody is
shitty when you have that many people
working for you it doesn't mean that
your whole [ __ ] company is racist and
needs to rethink everything about who
you are as a human being to figure out
his next move this is what you have to
do now though the elderly and absolutely
nothing if you just try to sweep it on
rug then you know what happens if the
boycotts come out yeah well as repairs I
mean it's not it's not a crazy point our
partner Troy makes a good point
I'm sorry partner try I didn't mean to
demean your points it's not a great your
point I did not mean that okay because
your point was valid and I accept it and
I hear you I do believe that you there
is a middle ground between blotchy
overreaction and sweeping it under the
rug you know if you fire the lady who
was called the cops if you go and meet
with the guys who are treated poorly you
can give him those happy gilmore
Starbucks for life cards do whatever you
got to do do something we don't turn
your company upside talent and the guys
weren't even dicks about it because the
guys took like a dollar in the lawsuit
with it but whatever like they they were
and the money that's gonna be donated to
something like to the city some City
yeah so the guys were definitely not
being dict no partners [ __ ] loaf yeah
waving he's not in it he's not he's not
I just
I do enjoy that partner [ __ ] loaf is
still partner [ __ ] like yeah it's good
one everyone feels welcome in common one
of our guys they didn't want to
acknowledge that we need to have a black
guys think in common one of our guides
what why do you need him as a guy he's
not he's not a corporate guy he doesn't
work for star club know what's common I
don't know he wasn't getting paid a lot
of money for this Allah I mean you talk
about corporate gigs this is one of the
great corporate gigs for common yeah
this really is and they're all gonna
just sit there do you know what the
executive table is gonna look like
listening to common talk like right
right oh yeah this is really a good
video this is good stuff this is good
stuff I've learned I don't hope everyone
here all my partner's will learn right
and I'll tell you something about common
he's anything but um yeah first name
should be on or something that's good
that's good stuff
we're gonna hear from our guides common
partnership as in-hand lyle jefferson to
bring some laughter yeah comedian lyle
chipper s'en will be here for our lunch
hey hey your face is all red what did
you [ __ ] fall in a period I just
understand the spirit of our meeting
yeah
my third place what does it mean um I'll
think of it
let's give partnership that time he
needs to think of his punchline it's
where everyone everyone feels welcome
why can't everyone twice that covers
everyone everyone it's like when you say
a word we see words twice I don't know
why what's it's to really add emphasis
and emphasis because it's really really
really important really important where
everyone everyone right because you're
sitting there he's sitting there going
oh I bet these guys watching this video
are thinking to themselves he doesn't
mean everyone oh no no every oh he does
everyone including common oh my god
comments here dick comment always brings
it home for me yes one of our guides
will help folks start exploring their
own identities helping people see each
other fully completely respectful me
once partners have gotten warmed up it's
good stuff it will start to explore this
what kind of warm up do you do about
warm up do you do for a racial training
video well you have to shake all those
prejudices out of your body just to get
back to your human form yeah human her
and all the same and its relation to our
mission Howard will join the
conversation and explain why the 3rd
place even matters its origin story I
know also share it capitalize the t and
the P in third place this is a
Scientology video this is they have gone
the extra mile they've gone past let's
train people to not be racist and
created a Starbucks cult that they're
trying to get everybody involved
you're right third place is capital T
and the PR capitalized and they keep
saying it even though nobody's ever said
that no
as they're trying so hard to be the at
the forefront of a cultural revolution
and they're bombing miserably
superheroes have origin stories right
right
not Starbucks 5:29 yeah 529 our third
place what is your origin story from one
human to another I want to sit down with
that
the CEO of that and go look Kevin I want
you to understand something you're an
ass what do you think the meetings were
like how many meetings did they have to
get all the terminology correct we'll
call it 529 we'll talk about the third
place would do it like there's so much
stuff in here that was all discovered in
a boardroom they want a brand to every
sentence they want a brand after a great
way to put they want a brand every
sentence it's it's this it's this young
embarrassingly progressive ideology
which removes any type of connection to
real life and corporate [ __ ] mixed
together and this is what you get is
that the words hurt when that came out
you get the corporate obsession with not
making another mistake with this this
idiotic it's not just progressive it's
like beyond progressive this is not this
is not necessarily as progressive this
is progressive scrubbed even cleaner by
a corporate lawyer this you're right
this goes beyond politics this is
corporate yeah you know and and like to
make it perfect for everyone everyone
everyone when Taco Bell created fourth
meal I was all for it because really
what they were saying is if you're drunk
or stoned late at night sure Taco Bell's
hoping you could get some tacos and he's
okay like I'm like okay I can get behind
that corporate strategy third place I
can not get behind third place they're
like work home Starbucks right yeah no I
think that's the third place I don't
know I've never heard of it it sounds
right so she's called the bronze [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how long until there's third place
branded merchandise oh my god yeah um
you know they're gonna make some oh my
god you know what yeah that's how
they're gonna make up for this day off
they're gonna sell a third place if you
bring in your third place cup tumbler
yeah relaxing
my third place I just hope that Nathan
fielder comes out with dumb third place
syndromes for this next era and so on a
personal level I want to ask you that
together we do everything we can to
build that third place in your store and
it's from this anchoring point that
partners move into a real and honest
exploration of bias everyone is well how
do you define hold on when you want sex
and your pay for it is I defined by it I
defined by ass as my co-host I'm never
gonna love a clip more than that ever
right it's great even you don't even
need it class so good it's so good an
experts from the perception Institute as
well as a store manager Explorer web by
I love his solemn look at the table boy
that guy in the suit no he's with he's
with three corporate women that's right
hey boy he better not [ __ ] up just nod
and he's got like the pencil mm-hmm
I'm taking this all in you know what
just occurred to me anybody that's
worked in retail or fast casual food
service the douche bag Troy you've
worked in food service partner I'm sorry
partner Troy if I'm not mistaken as a
human being you've you've had a
profession in food service I've worked
at Starbucks you've worked at Starbucks
okay
the douchebags that end up being store
managers of those places these douche
bags are the ones that are going to be
leading up team meetings and trying to
get the employees to construct a third
place in their store oh yeah there they
take it very seriously I'm sure they're
watching this Emilio okay this is what
we're doing team we need to get it
together
I'm sure it's and what are all the what
are all the employees doing they're just
kind of rolling their eyes and going
with it because they need the job right
but what the [ __ ] is it
paid to do nothing but sit there right
and by the way half of these guys who
become women who become corporate like
the top they don't even come from
Starbucks they're just corporate people
and like um front of the corporation
like this [ __ ] CEOs don't work their
way up they come from Kmart or they come
from some other Sears and then they run
this place that's how you know Starbucks
is not special the CEO from like NASCAR
is now the CEO of Starbucks because
coffee and racecar driving or whatever
that guy is no no I'm just saying they
get like you you hear when a new CEO
comes in he's just the CEO of a
completely unrelated company before this
store managers don't care and of course
not it's just it's it's a bear it's it's
a thirty thousand forty thousand dollar
a year job my store manager burger can
put soap in the burgers of people he
didn't like they're not these amazing
people know they're not did that's the
other think the store managers they're
making enough money to get by but
they're not sitting there being like
yeah Starbucks is really changing my
life cuz they're not watch usually you
know they're uncomfortable because their
mouths are all shut close like nodding
like when you're just sitting there
talking your mouth doesn't have to hang
open like a mouth-breathing idiot but
their mouths are not relaxed you know
why because they're just sitting there
per slipped waiting for the other person
to completely be done talking there's no
conversation of like let me jump in here
and let me interject there it's just
keep your mouth shut and then when it's
your turn to speak speak [ __ ] jacket
is awful Hearst would you say it looks
like a cheese grater her jacket and just
stupid purpley the [ __ ] Joker people
rubbing parmesan blocks on her chest an
experts from the perception Institute as
well as a Starbucks tour manager hello
what's the [ __ ] perception Institute
I don't know maybe it's where they
invent third places what is it that
that's what let's look what this [ __ ]
perception Institute
what's an expert from the perception
Institute okay the perception Institute
inspires people to live their values our
brains like to be right our hearts
strive to be good the very
experience of racial difference however
can send these basic human impulses a
Twitter right Instagram
unless disrupted stereotypes embedded in
our brains can turn into implicit bias
and lead to discrimination overtime and
racial anxiety the concern that we might
confirm our own biases or experience
bias from someone else makes racial
navigation even more challenged so this
is who's Starbucks went to yes for help
this was their PR move they went to the
perception Institute right who I took
most of this [ __ ] I'm sure they did I
took from that that one of the racial
anxiety is when you're afraid you might
be racist yeah right yeah and that
believe me that is what all those
[ __ ] white people and upper
management or experienced national
anxiety absolute they're afraid that the
fact that they feel just a little better
and just a little smarter is gonna be
obvious right now it says about
perception Institute perception
Institute is a consortium of researchers
advocates and strategists who translate
cutting-edge mind science research on
race gender ethnic ethnic and other
identities into solutions that reduce
bias and discrimination and promote
belonging we work in sectors where bias
is the most profound impact education
healthcare media workplace law
enforcement and civil justice
it's just [ __ ] it's it's we don't need
this right it's not needed do you think
Starbucks came up with the idea that
they're gonna start calling himself the
third place or do you think that the
racial institute did I think it was
Starbucks that was like and I think that
you're a hundred percent right they said
we want home we won't work we want us
let's start calling ourselves to the
third place you know I don't know who
brands these things but the perception
Institute may do that but just how again
the perception Institute right its
robotic there's nothing human about it
is this this discussion and what you're
seeing here in this language is
literally like something that would have
been in a movie in 1985 or 1986 in the
future we will belong to the perception
Institute where from human to human we
will enjoy our third
place its its Westworld [ __ ] we're being
taught how to perceive it's that
perception in and of itself is supposed
to be just that
the human experience is sloppy it's not
it's not pristine right it's not
completely cut and dry and it's not
without gray areas this it's not how it
works
we have prejudices we have biases hey
look if you're gonna be a racially
insensitive [ __ ] you really get fired
you're gonna stop being that way we used
to call them grey areas but going
forward we're not gonna mention color
that's a good point because we're color
what is it
color brave my colorblind because it
brave
we're color brave here so no more gray
areas it will be just call it an area
yeah how about an areas of ambiguity yes
areas of ambiguity what is this what
everybody's been pushing a lot of people
in pushing for forever of like this
perfect utopian we are all one there is
no male or female we are all just humans
just it just seems like that everybody's
trying to recondition people's brains to
be thinking this way well I don't know
if I go that far we're trying to wipe
out the ugly thoughts that we have in
the ugly instincts that we write so we
figure if we like say these things these
at the bottom line is if people are
having these thoughts and you're having
these feelings and there's they're there
we're trying to pretend that they're not
there then all this is is whitewashing
this is literally just taking a nice
little picture and putting it over an
ugly picture and hoping that no one sees
the ugly picture underneath it's not
real right we're just gonna hope that a
breeze doesn't come by and blow away the
nice picture exactly that's exactly what
it is and we're hoping that if we leave
the nice picture on top of the ugly
picture that the nice picture will
become reality and it's not the way it
is because you you this is not how
people think of course unrealistic it's
not connected to the way anybody
interacts no no and not everybody is
this you know demonic villain but there
are there's levels to all this stuff
like there's there's you can't just have
there's not one human experience that's
just like this is how things are gonna
be perceived
can you imagine five hundred years from
now though how
we'll communicate it will be this
robotic at all it really will be you
think so a hundred percent look it's got
in twenty years in terms of language
language please
and and thoughts will eventually will
have in there already starting to be
able to see what you can dream and what
like what what little electrons were
ever fire off when you think of certain
letters the Minority Report to get it
what they're getting close to being able
to do that boy and eventually once they
can do that forget it all bad thoughts
will be wiped out negative thoughts will
be penalized
so you're saying it'll be paradise yes
it will be yes finally we'll finally be
where we've always needed to be if you
wouldn't mind partner Troy could we
continue thank you very much for what
bias means and how it shows up every day
in each and every one of us so today
when we close down our stores to get
more training and hopefully come away
with whether they apparently did this is
one take I think you [ __ ] fix that
stupid boys can we rewind that awful
moment well the only one talking you
know why she paused because it was she
said today when we close our stores she
didn't know what day it was right right
because it's not it's not actually
filmed that day and then she realized
should I brand 529 right yes you
remember the date she thought she was
gonna get in trouble from her boss she's
like that was a branding opportunity
that you missed yeah it also while she's
talking the guy was just sitting across
from her this middle finger up watch
watching and seeing what she's talking
he's got eyes today when we closed down
our stores - is that guy mouthing [ __ ]
you she's a [ __ ] it's totally on Gulf
War and hopefully come away with more
learnings around bias can we
structurally change the organization so
I think we would say more learnings like
saying monies we might want to sound
important I put an S on it
they just learning's inappropriately
PluralEyes who says learning's it's
never been said before but we're hoping
for some more learnings
doesn't make any sense like a little kid
talking it really is your child talk I'm
glad she's piping in notice her yeah I'm
happy she's finally chiming in he's good
yeah he's good actual work is something
that has to be done for far longer than
the four hour day and that's policy
that's the work the company has to do to
support the partners in the individual
work because one of the things look
[ __ ] look at the Manchurian Candidate
look on this poor guy's face
yeah just sitting there look and look at
the guys uh if you want to watch this
later it's called Starbucks racial bias
training preview and will tweet out the
video if we agree that it's [ __ ]
phenomenal it's amazing watch the guy
it's about two minutes in and there's a
guy at the table with three women and
look at his face like he doesn't even
want to make the wrong facial expression
right he doesn't want his real thoughts
which is huh doesn't want you to know
that's what's on his mind to support the
partners in the individual work because
one of the things we don't want to see
is for each person to have to bear this
burden alone after a bit of learning and
inspiration partners will explore a bias
personally and how it shows up in each
of their lives when I first started
working there I had to deal with
difficult homeless customers all the
time so what happened was I would put
flammable liquid on them and I would say
get out of here you bums and then I
would throw a match at them as I kicked
him into the street yeah
my manager kept a tub of kerosene under
the cash register at all times in cases
he said the hobo problem resurfaced yes
or I would keep a fly swatter under and
I would repeatedly hit their face and
say get out of here you pants [ __ ]
insects right I learned what I could do
with a lighter and a can of hairspray
but I would shoot fireballs at the
homeless yeah this guy gets it wrong
he's like these [ __ ] bums like you
can't say that do it they'll then
explore the realities and impact of
racial discrimination in public
accommodations they're showing stuff
from this Martin Luther King marches
what Starbucks wasn't even around them
it's a coffee problem we don't need to
go this far back and trying to they want
it to have weight and
importance they do part of the part of
529 mm-hmm was showing a documentary
about public at the history of public
and justice oh that's smart didn't know
before now I wasn't sure what happened I
thought that America was pretty utopian
all woman apparently did you know that
there were marches in the 60s
well like throughout the month no in the
1960s there were marches no no no not
marches know like people marching well
technically yes
I don't want it Travis is technically
right there were twelve marks it's my
truth and there were ten marches in the
60s there were also other marches for
justice but yes you're both technically
correct as as human beings but different
but still same so what is showing
colored waiting room yeah I also love
that they were talking about the
bathroom and their experiences their
traumatic experiences of watching
homeless people shoot up in the bathroom
and how does Starbucks respond by
putting a [ __ ] revolving door on the
bathroom for anybody that wants to use
it and by the way now they have they
have a black-and-white photo colored
waiting room and there's a black guy
underneath it and you what they ought to
do they ought to show now in Harvard
University black graduation because
that's what they're doing they had a
black only graduation for black students
the black people were that blacks
weren't invited to I guess for whatever
reason they want to show that things
change but they don't really change
we're on time of the sixties Jim no no
no but they should show today we're just
like about the 60s but they push
shouldn't they show just gonna talk
about the sixties but why not use Rosa
Parks now there's a being legally
mandated now it's kind of almost a Rosa
Parks a self segregation at times for
socially just reasons as people see it I
don't know could somebody have partner
Jim step out of the room we have to do
we have to talk to him he's but there
was the hard week graduation step out
this is almost like the more things
change the more they stay the same but
different [ __ ] cool tattoo from the
civil rights movement all the way to
today partners will be joined by
award-winning documentarian see right
there go back
that's a nice moment look they're
showing some some diners and some police
about to have a nice meal together it
wasn't was the police are checking in on
their meal look at that making sure that
they've been look how you enjoying your
meal
nice photos going on yes there's two
black customers and there's literally
sex police officers they're making sure
that their meal is satisfactory did I
not tell you this is the best burger in
town
all right joy very nice yeah board
winning documentarian Stanley Nelson as
he presents his film you're welcome I
try to make sure I make eye contact with
people they may or may not be security
or managerial staff just ensure that you
know I'm not here to hide anything i
watch my tone to make sure that i don't
come off as threatening just leaving the
house some days you know it's Intel just
keep you at home okay I don't know who
this man is but why is he menacing I
don't like that it seems like part of
the training is also teaching black
people how to speak and make eye contact
well then what are we watching I think
he's saying that as a black man he has
to do that oh he doesn't come off as
scary oh and he doesn't want people to
prejudge him as being frightening so
he'll do things he's it's like he has to
walk in and go I'm not stealing Jim you
said as soon as as soon as his face was
on screen though you jumped out of your
chair you said did I hid his cornrows
let's see watch a bit of Kevin and
Ross's reaction to the film oh good if
there's one thing I want it's Kevin and
Roz's reaction I'd rather watch the
reaction of two girls one cop but Kevin
and Roz you think so Oh Kevin and Roz
could eat a bag of [ __ ] Kevin is the
crying CEO yes he is Roz is his friend
who's Roz I want to see him watch a bit
of Kelly Kevin's emotional again
clubbing fool we all learned something
from Stanley Nelson's film wouldn't your
personal takeaways Kevin just snapped
you know what we don't need is blacks
menacing our employees we're trying to
say Kevin no Kevin he's ready yeah yeah
we want the Don Lemon Kevin at least Roz
looks like a fun person to be around it
makes those [ __ ] glasses
personal takeaways for me I think it's
sobering
I mean it just highlights this is a long
journey yeah and a long strop staring up
when I saw this and thought about public
accommodations I began to think about
racial anxiety Oh being african-american
myself and how I feel when I walk into
some venues I know what that feels like
once the film is over partners will also
hear re commitments to policy guidelines
and leadership from senior leaders at
Starbucks this is the first step and
there's some more work to be done for
sure
Kevin is smiling now he is Kevin is
smiling he's been to African American
women and everyone's getting along yeah
Kevin gets it he's like happy are we
happy
are we happy he's happy I've never been
around two of them at once and I'm doing
pretty good
hey guys he's looking right into the
camera
not bad huh not bad there's two of them
I haven't even thought at once yeah I'm
a pretty good white guy oh just jesting
you just see a mouth the word what are
you doing I just I thought I thought I
thought that look at his self-satisfied
smirk like I'm doing pretty good here
this this is what it's about
does he wear that stupid purple sweater
and every appearance he has never seen
him without a purple sweater it's
terrible his red face it was worth the
price of admission to see his dumb smile
and red face
red-faced idiot he's a white guy yeah he
can't wait to get involved in some of
the leadership training we've got
planned we'll bring the two
conversations together by exploring how
partners can work to create a more this
guy is uncomfortable no shoulder stance
it's like DeRosa if he was black scare
beef you scared me for a second the
guy's name is Tasman MB I don't know
it's a ma MBO mochi mochi mochi mochi
he's a district manager I really thought
for a second that's not like okay wait
I'm so stupid
yeah Michael K Williams shoulders don't
slant down diagonally through his ear
it's amazing I mean he's got his hand on
the thing for balance because he's
nervous yeah bring the two conversations
together bikes
the partners can work to create a
minimal answer yeah get you a notebook
out and turn to what makes me me okay
and you together for a second I'm gonna
get my notebook out yeah what makes me
me I have you could tell me what page
page is that [ __ ] okay not words that
you should be using I'm sorry I'm not
trying to be unpardonably a [ __ ] page
number what makes me me and you you oh
wow there's a lot of there's workbook
stuff in this notebook I know there's so
much in that notebook what pages is on
come on partner Tefft let's continue on
with the video god [ __ ] damn it and
you you together partners will explore
inspiration partner stories and
problem-solve using new tools to
reiterate our coming tools to pedigree
Oh know what Jim the commitment I can't
even say it just let it play rate our
commitment to the green apron well
that's what they refer to their jobs our
commitment to the green apron dude
Starbucks is a cult
yeah a commitment to the green apron in
the third place uplifting people I'm
telling you this is half racial bias
training half let's start indoctrinating
people into the Starbucks cult this is
worse than like the [ __ ] Apple used to
do do you have a commitment to the green
this is worse but then with Jim Jones
used to do you have a commitment to the
green apron we'll have you been
listening to my on on Roz yeah it's the
exact same thing it's the exact same
thing is and problem-solve using new
tools to reiterate our commitment to the
green apron what we look like in action
when we are truly at our best
ultimately 5:29 will focus on creating
belonging in our stores and learning
about what gets in the way but remember
5:29 will just be a star okay you hear
how these insincere piles of [ __ ] are
branding five twenty five twenty nine
third-place 529 commitment to the green
they're gonna have some kind of 529 cup
like you said that was ago or something
you're right that's how they're gonna
make the money from closing the store
for the day
yeah 529 but then again this was if they
did release this publicly on 529 we made
our commitment to the green apron
everything changed
Leah Remini is gonna be doing a
documentary about Starbucks at any
moment yeah she really well and they
took me in the back and they put a
plunger in my anus in my green apron in
my ear but remember 529 will just be a
start in the coming weeks months and
years we will address many other facets
of what makes us truly human good
yeah and part of that by the way is our
ugly thoughts yeah the fact that we're
different we all have a little prejudice
in us we all have a little bit a little
bit these are people who earn vacation
time by the minute starker Patty used to
come in here and say that she's
collected four hours of vacation time
and now they wanted to commit to the
green apron oh why would you need a
vacation from the third place yeah
sounds like a wonderful place it does
yeah of what makes us truly human
the work will grow to reflect the
realities of our abilities ethnicities
gender identities and expressions sexual
identities class language citizenship
political views religious affiliations
and more it won't be perfect but we are
all in this together
oh good good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
yeah political views let's see how many
make America great again hats there are
well everybody's allowed right or no oh
whoops
Wow it's crazy it's crazy did this cult
like yeah once I got sincere all right
it's a company panicking I thought it
was just kind of corporate speak
overreaction asinine stuff until I
watched that video and it was like the
language that's used the branding of
every other word it is so scary
cult-like now this is what this is a
video I know what no it's just the New
Yorker posting an article about it and
that's just the intro video that's just
the intro there's 20 videos in there
indoctrination that's just called always
a four-hour thing yeah that's just
didn't that that's a five-minute video
explaining what's gonna be happening
yeah
then there's 20 more now to come and go
to all the Starbucks no no he was in
some of the videos oh good yeah those
are up on their website what a great gig
for common made a ton of money oh boy
did he just got to go into like a
warehouse and be like hey I'm common
probably got a lot of third place merch
early China third place merch
what do you think is better the third
place of the third shift Oh
third shift John and Jeff yeah
definitely they would totally be honest
yeah we're two humans the short film
these are some people left me humbled
after today's training thank you for
sharing it with us as a Starbucks
partners barista at Starbucks I can say
that the course we went through today
was absolutely phenomenal incredible
well organized course to help confront
unconscious bias as we all face in our
daily lives the inclusion of film made
it especially powerful all these Twitter
accounts belong to
CEOs wife yeah they're all just burner
accounts yes boy that that president
red-faced class act blotchy but fair
yeah I mean some of the stuff in this
like notebook I love that Travis he
printed out the entire team guidebook
and notebook because he believes in it
for both Jim and I to not only have but
study and read I want you guys to better
yourselves now that you're not good
already but we can always we all need
improvement I appreciate that partner
Tefft yet the perception Institute's
Alexis McGill Johnson yeah these are all
from the perception Institute I mean and
then like the work exercises are like
the first time you number one noticed
your racial identity I know I remember
for me when it was when I walked through
a room and people just began applauding
okay I don't know I think we can work
how about the first time you noticed how
race affected your beauty standards um I
know that there's been many instances
but this is the first one right the
first time the very first time you're
sitting there and you're going like you
know what my beauty standards are
affected by my race do you remember I
think when I went over to my friends
house he happened to be non-white okay
that's all I want to ask anyway than
anything man he and his family were
there and they were just touching my
hair never saying how come we get ours
like this that's bad yeah it's no good
okay no good no good
what's okay we'll move on to number
three or four number three the first
time you felt your accent impacted
people's perception of your intelligence
or competence do you remember when the
was it when you look back the way you
speak nah cuz okay that's it's not your
accent I don't remember okay we'll leave
it at that
how about the first time you Alton okay
this is not gonna be a good one
Travis do you know what number four is I
see you laughing no but I know I read
them all before the first time you
altered your communication style dialed
up or down to avoid playing into
stereotypes probably January 8th 1981
what happened then
I was talking to some black friends and
decided to be like them what was your
year Big Daddy James started talking
yeah y'all uh
man I don't know
I ain't never be affecting my
communication styles was so bad terrible
just terrible embarrassing really you're
trying to follow the guy since in New
Brunswick can we keep walking ahead of
me didn't want to be seen with me what
were you saying to him go wait up man
why would you talk like that I don't
know hey glasses your dork was a
complete dork like a nerd
yo man wait up yo how you talk man no
it's not never what wasn't it all never
was was a suburban nerd who blew his
friends we isolate that please then
there's like essay portions where they
come on that's a Latin stereotype oh
there he is hip hop Jimmy looks like a
young Jeff Dahmer honestly does because
they see the hair the calyx thong a
great set of hair or head of hair hey
hair you got a great set of hairs look
at the way all those hairs come together
but that was after going to the barber
and having it like literally he styled
it and part of it and that was hair
right holding it from flopping him I
hated my hairs you go to the barber and
go okay can you give me the horse's ass
yes I did and he did my time that guy
why the trouble
kid that's true you were probably Justin
just right before this photo going like
this
uh-oh and shaking that knot or okay
that's right that's right
they want you to write an entire page
behind the question what is being
present with someone mean to you what is
being present awesome look at them okay
no good you're not good at this by the
way I'm assuming these notebooks were
not collected right no those are 100%
for you this would be like when you're
in school they would do this sometimes
in school they would have you fill out
these notebooks and you would just go
home with them to reflect on them
I would never answer one question in
them never know if you're not gonna
check my work I'm not doing it yeah
you're a reflection I would do what's
that what it was like to look on the
inside of the trash can as I dropped it
you throw it in the garbage yeah
shucks indeed how does it feel when a
Starbucks customer is not engaged or
present with you or a fellow partner
good because who the how engaged you
want with a [ __ ] Starbucks customer
did you want your customers coming in
and becoming your great friends that's
why we have mobile ordering now where
they just leave the drink on the counter
and we go in and you don't have to talk
to anyone
yeah oh my gosh this is a two page
question and this is all from the
Starbucks notebook that they gave out
yesterday or whenever awesome what is
the single most impactful thing you will
do to bring your team's commitments to
life please write two pages but that's a
single thing that's true what's the
single most important thing you'll do
smile just wrote the word smile what's
the rest boy yeah oh my god it's amazing
it's incredible that this is real life
Starbucks is one of the biggest
companies there is it's real life that's
why they're doing this oh the good press
that they got someone's gonna lead yeah
are they getting good press or do a lot
of people think it's ridiculous it's the
people have to know it's idiotic yes
complete [ __ ] Larry the back of the
of the notebook just says the words my
thoughts and then it leaves several
blank pages for you to write here the
[ __ ] is writing
our thoughts in the back of this
Starbucks manual how empty are we is
people that we gotta write them in the
back of a Starbucks manual or they go
home and blog about it go or vlog vlog
you want to do yeah go vlog on YouTube
that Starbucks thinks that this is gonna
help it this is what people want to do
write down their thoughts in the back of
their Starbucks I would love to have
Patti bring hers in oh my god she still
works at Starbucks yeah yeah contact her
I would love to see what she wrote in
hers
ask you again you know she took it
seriously yeah and I also know that she
voted for Trump Oh boys yeah oh boy yeah
can you come in next week maybe Wow